good morning everybody and for some of
you i know that it is not morning so
forgive me afternoon evening wherever
you are
we are glad that you are here with us
today for the next two hours we are
going to be sharing some powerful
information that is empowering
because
as individuals we can make choices we
have this thing behind our between our
ears
that allows us to be able to think
logically and it's like
you know there's just some things that
don't sound right so let's look at
something else
and i am so excited that we are able to
bring that something else to you on the
ask doc live which is what you're
plugged into today is ask doc live this
program is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com
where you will find all of the products
that are mentioned in today's program dr
wallach's most
popular publications are found there as
well including the 10 good foods bad
foods list that he mentions
very often
in this program but i want to remind you
that if somebody specifically shared
this program with you please get back
with them they cared enough about you to
share this program with you to get
information because that's what we are
we are a resource for information
of alternatives that you can do on your
own
to create a better health journey
my name is rebecca kozak i will be your
host for the next two hours and i am
joined with my wonderful co-hosts jonty
mccollier ruth ellen sanchez and nasima
omar
and we are excited to be able to bring
this information to you if you are on
live with us today we do go through and
call on people for their questions based
on the order that their hand is raised
so in the zoom menu you will find
a raise hand options sometimes you
excuse me sometimes you have to click on
reactions
and you'll find that raised hand option
but please
this is a time that you have available
to you to ask the man himself
questions in regards to what you can do
nutritionally
to
improve your health situations
i do have to remind you that the content
of this program is for educational
information only it is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
all the information that is shared in
this program
um
is to help you not just survive but
thrive you know when the body is given
what it needs it can do some amazing
things but the fdi
fda does require us to let you know that
our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program again is not meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician
but we bring good news
the genetic theory has been proven
incorrect through the science of
epigenetics
which is the study of how your behaviors
and your environment can cause changes
that affect the way your genes work
so with epigenetics you are an empowered
individual and have more control than
you think over your health journey and
we invite you to feel the difference
with the options that are shared in this
program
to guide us on this journey we are so
honored to be able to have with us one
of the founding fathers of epigenetics
here to share the best options to obtain
or maintain
optimal health we're not just here for
the sick we're here for those who want
to stay healthy
as well
so dr wallach dr joel wallach welcome to
ask doc live
thank you so much for taking time out of
your schedule
and i know that we're going to have some
great testimonials on today which i want
to remind our listeners these are the
testimonials of the individual
themselves they are not paid
and
they're just excited at the progress
that they've made using the products
that you've been so instrumental in
formulating dr wallach
so welcome
well thank you
appreciate that and
i have to
um
share with you that uh
you know and i don't know maybe by next
week or certainly by two weeks we're
going to have a big big news release out
as the news releases go around the world
because we've figured out a lot of stuff
i mean we're doing so much research
right now we've figured out a lot of
stuff
and one of the things is before we get
into the subject of the day
we figured out
what caused the five mass extinctions
we figured out you know we're talking
like in the year
two billion years ago kind of thing
right
five mass distinct extinctions where
thousands of species disappeared now
they they you know people want you to
think they disappeared overnight but it
was about a hundred thousand years it
took for them to die out
100 000 years it wasn't like overnight
but i guess in time of billions of years
a hundred thousand years is pretty quick
and then
um then we had of course
the dinosaurs died they were the most
successful vertebrates
they lived but depending on whose
numbers you looked at 165 million to 235
million years
but then they went away in a mass
extinction okay again a hundred thousand
years
and then we have something going on
um called dead zones
there's 400 dead zones the newest one is
farming off the west coast of oregon and
these are places in the ocean
where nothing lives there's no plants
there's no animals nothing if an animal
tries to get in there
the floor in these dead zones is
littered with the bodies of everything
from crabs to fish to porpoises and they
get these dead zones the biggest one
is in the arabian sea
and um
in india which is the northern main
country north of the arabian sea all the
rivers go into there
um
had
and still has 100 now let me back up has
10 000 glaciers
okay so i'm giving it a kind of a clue
there it has ten thousand glaciers
all right
and then
um
the
the dead zone in the arabian sea is 63
700 square miles
the second largest dead zone is in the
gulf of mexico
and it's 6
square miles of dead zones
and then of course we have another issue
um we have all of the reefs are dying
many of them are already dead many of
them are dying
and then we have our problem right now
with the pandemic
now you're probably too young to
remember two years ago
but two years ago when this coven 19
came out
all the experts said look just put on a
mask wash your hands distance yourself
six feet this is a nothing bug it's not
going to hurt anybody uh we're in the
process in a couple of months we'll have
a vaccine it's a nothing thing it's not
going to be a big deal
well what do we have here right now
what do we have for this not a big deal
right now we have 40 million 520
784 infections
40 million that's just the united states
that's not the world that's just the
united states 40 million infections as
more than ten percent of our population
forty million five hundred twenty
thousand seven hundred eighty four that
was this morning's numbers notice this
morning's numbers for dead is six
hundred and sixty two thousand nine
hundred and forty five now just before
noon today it'll be over 663 000
and you have to appreciate
the which had been the biggest pandemic
that the united states ever had at least
registered
with the spanish flu in 1918 1919 two
years
they had
um six hundred
and fifty seven thousand dead we've
exceeded it by five years already
or not five years by five thousand
people it's gonna be five thousand
people
and the two years isn't up yet
and so we've exceeded we've already far
exceeded the spanish flu
and this is because
we haven't done our part to protect
ourselves
and i blame this entirely on the medical
profession you have to appreciate um the
average lifespan of medical doctors and
hospitals is 57 years of age
average lifespan and medical doctor
particularly in the in the emergency
rooms is 57 years that's from the cdc a
year ago center for disease control
that's not my
cdc statistics
and why is it the people who should know
how to live the longest to be the
healthiest only there would be 57.
okay they're giving up over 90 years
okay so they know nothing about health
and longevity now if you get run over by
a truck and you're bleeding internally
you got to go to them but when it comes
to asking about how do i live to be 100
they're not the ones you want to ask
what you want to do of course
is do everything correctly so you can
add 25 to 50 health years your life
that's my goal is to give everybody
enough information and have available to
them everything they need add 25 to 50
healthier life
we have that now we have everything
for the covet we have the colloidal
silver i've been taking cold silver two
droppers full 30 minutes for each meal
and 30 minutes before bedtime for 25
years our colloidal silver
okay i just did mine this morning i'm
going to you know do it again at
lunchtime do it again dinner time to get
a bed time and then of course we have
our um killer biotic which is mushrooms
that support the immune system we have
the cell shield rtq and q is quercetin
which all the medical records come out
and say quercetin is one of the biggest
things to support your immune system so
i take three of those three times a day
or cell shield rtq for the quercetin
and then
um
i use our oxy body
instead of you know drinking
a cola i drink oxy body and then of
course i drinkers our sports drink or
rebound i drink two of those a day i
only weigh 142 pounds i drink two of
those a day i have so much energy
i only sleep two hours at a time then
i'll wake up and then i have to work
in russia and
japan then i'll go to sleep for two
hours and i'll wake up and then i have
to work in iraq and india and then i go
to sleep for and so i'm working
about um
i'd say 18 hours a day
now because we're trying to save as many
as we can and um
do you want me to just go right into the
subject of the day yeah let's just let's
go right into it as soon as you're ready
okay i'm ready
did you want to introduce it
yeah so
there's a lot of things going on right
now dr wallach has to do with mental
health
and many things are things that have
just
you know increased
over the last two years because of
what's going on and some of them have
just been quote unquote diagnosed with
mental illness like conditions
called schizophrenia
so dr wallach share with us a little bit
about the cause of schizophrenia and
other mental illnesses and what we can
do
to overcome these conditions
okay well first of all the brain
like the heart and your liver your
kidneys your muscles your intestines
your lungs
from your thyroid gland and center
center certain skin
all tissues of the body including the
brain all organs in the body including
the brain require
90 essential nutrients
okay
and people say well i'm eating right
well that doesn't matter
because plants only need three elements
to make good seeds for the next
generation
and farmers
when they use commercial fertilizer they
only have npk in there those three
elements that plants need
and then of course for themselves and
their animals they use vitamins and
minerals
but they want to pay the least to get
the most when it comes to tonnage per
acre and so they use these commercial
fertilizers that have npk nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium in there and
that will give them the maximum yield
they get paid by tons and bushels
farmers do not get paid by the
nutritional value of the food
so if you think you're eating well and
you're not supplementing and you're
you're cooking badly
um you're in deep doo-doo okay the
bright the brain requires 90 essential
nutrients minimum
and this needs to start a minimum of six
months before you're conceived
this needs to start a minimum of six
all these young girls who you know are
six eight ten years old they're
nearing puberty they better be taking
the 90 essential nutrients they better
be staying away from the bad foods
and
um this is imperative
because when the brain is forming if
you're missing stuff
you're going to be born
missing stuff
okay
in many cases you cannot fix it because
when pieces are missing
you can't re you can't regrow them or
grow them
after you're born
and so i urge and whether you plan on
having a baby or not you better be
taking the 90th cents of nutrients you
know what this cool covered thing going
on and everybody locked up in their
houses
and not being able to get out and move
around
oh gosh we weren't planning on getting
pregnant but you know we had a couple
glasses of wine and you know things
happen
and so yeah well this is happening more
and more and more and more and babies
are born with cleft palates they're born
blind they're born cycloptic with one
eye in the middle of their forehead
they're born with heart defects they're
born with spina bifida they're born
with all these problems they're also
born
um
with gender issues
okay
gender issues are caused by
a deficiency
early in the formation of the brain
when the hypothalamus is formed the
hypothalamus determines who you're going
to chase for sex
okay regardless of your gender what's
between your legs doesn't matter to your
brain
it's going to go far whatever
it's told to do
and if you're not getting the 90th cents
of nutrients that brain when that part
of the hypothalamus is farming
it's kind of like cerebral palsy
kids are born with cerebral palsy they
have you know a problem with balance and
and um
they they aren't coordinating all that
kind of stuff because
the parts of the brain and the
cerebellum
the brain stem that actually control
balance and
that sort of stuff uh coordination
are missing because mama was missing
nutrients when that part of the brain
was farming
the brain doesn't stop and say okay i'll
just go to sleep here until that
nutrient shows up no it just keeps
marching on and that piece is missing
you're born with cerebral palsy you're
born with a gender issue um
these things are not choices
and
um you know i've been shown here in the
last couple of weeks china's going crazy
right now over gender issue problems
they're making it a law
that the people with gender issues
can't get married and have kids
they will force them to have an abortion
if they get pregnant if they have a
gender issue
okay now somebody with a gender issue
can have a normal baby if they are
taking all the 90 cents of nutrients
because it's not a genetic thing
so they can be born with a piece missing
but then
if they're not taking all the 90 cents
of nutrients they can also have a baby
with all the other birth defects as well
and so
the same thing is true with brain
function when it comes to adding up
numbers the same thing is true with the
brain when it comes to behavior whether
you can be civilized and sit at the
table and um you know eat with a fork
and a spoon like you've been taught to
do as a kid or if you're picking up your
food with your hand and your fist and
putting on your face
those things
are all caused by nutritional
deficiencies
in the brain
and so i cannot stress enough
your priority your priority for
everybody in the family
is to take those 90 essential nutrients
stay away from the bad boosting maximize
absorption and the bad foods are of
course gluten is the major subject here
no wheat by the rhinos well what do you
mean don't eat brother rhinos wheat is a
biblical thing well yeah
you go look at
the 10 plagues
what were the egyptians eating uh uh
uh wait
okay
they actually started out with barley
and then when they weren't getting
enough yield they were introduced to
wheat and they added wheat to so they're
getting barley and wheat both high
gluten grains
and so they got 10 years
of the plague
okay
and that's because they were eating
wheat
now
the hebrews who was enslaved to them for
400 years didn't didn't get the plague
now how could that be so i spent a lot
of time i spent six months going through
all the records and found out what all
that
hebrew slaves did for 400 years for the
egyptians well it turns out
they didn't clean the house they didn't
babysit
they didn't do any of that kind of stuff
they didn't cook what they did do
was
manage
the um fields of barley and wheat what
they did do was by hand of course they
didn't have tractors in those days so by
hand they would pull the weeds out
between the rose or the grain and they
would also carry buckets of water on one
of those big yokes and two buckets on
each side you know and they would water
the wheat and barley fields
and then they would harvest
the wheat
and they would
then hand it over to the egyptians
we're talking about tens of thousands of
acres because their entire armies were
fed that that's where their armies were
dying that's why the the wealthy were
dying that's why the people in the
government were dying because they're
eating barley and wheat they're getting
gluten problems
and when the bugs came through they had
no defense
and they were just dying like flies and
the hebrews didn't lose one person
to the plagues
because they were forced to eat potatoes
and beans
and maize corn and vegetables and stuff
like that of course they had meat head
fish and
dairy
which is all kind of kosher stuff
okay
and so that's why there's this disparity
between
the hebrews not getting the plague and
all the egyptians dying from the plague
it was what they were eating
okay it's just that simple
and so when it comes to again your
behavior
this is controlled by portions of your
brain and those portions of your brain
require the ninety essential nutrients
and one of the ways
you can guarantee
to get the nutrition of course is to
take
the healthy brain and heart pack that's
why he came out with a healthy brain and
heart pack
now
people can accuse me a lot of things but
i don't have schizophrenia
they can say i'm crazy they can say i'm
too aggressive they can see all kinds of
things
but
i don't have
those types of problems because i've
been taken for 74 years i've been eating
the
90 essential nutrients and avoiding
gluten for 74 years
now
um the healthy brain and heart pack i i
only weigh 142 pounds but i dose myself
for a 200 pound man i take two healthy
brain hard picks per month
okay
i take the sweeties i don't have
diabetes but i take the sweeties i take
three of those twice a day just to help
control my blood sugar all right i take
the
glucogel
and this of course is to support um
the skull
i want to you know make sure my skull is
okay and my joints my jaw and
everything's okay
my
vertebrae and my
disc between the vertebrae my neck and
so on so that my spinal cord is happy
right
and
not bad for an 82 year old guy
okay and so it's one of those things
where
i pay attention all that we have another
one which we call the flexi care plus
and this when you look at the label on
the back
we formulated this in our laboratories
formula it's a formulated product
and the nutrients in here equal
um
the
soup broth okay bone broth
where you just take bones and put some
vinegar in with it just simmer it on the
stove all night and we'd fight over in
the morning who's going to get the
biggest share of the bone broth well
that was so good for joints whether it's
your your vertebrae
your your neck bones your
disc in between the vertebrae and your
skull
your jaw bones
everybody knew that that bone broth
could fix things and prevent things from
happening so that's why we came out with
the flexi care plus this is available
there's two servings a day in here
for um so there's 60 servings in here
for an adult
60 servings two a day for 30 days a
month and so i go through
one of these bottles a month myself here
in the house
and then i ate two eggs
three times a day or eat three eggs two
times a day okay i eat six eggs a day
with soft yolks and so
this is for my brain your brain is 75
cholesterol by weight
and so when they came out with
um
things like statin drugs to lower your
cholesterol and told you to stop eating
eggs and stop eating animal fat and all
that kind of stuff
they created alzheimer's disease they
created
more and more and more people having
these brain issues memory issues
behavioral issues
okay
inability to remember stuff inability to
acquire knowledge
now remember when you're born with a
problem like a cleft palate it's a
surgical issue
when you're born with a gender issue
you really got a problem because
you either have to take hormones or have
surgery um
or whatever to deal with what you got
okay and so there's about five or six
different choices there whether you're
going to stay the way you are
whether you're going to have some
surgery and mechanically
change your
your um
physical stuff in between your legs to
to match what's going on in your head i
mean there's all kinds of stuff that
needs to happen here if you're going to
have a reasonably
um
stable life
okay but schizophrenia is very common
it's very simple nutritional
deficiencies
you see this a lot in war zones where
people don't have access to consistent
access to good food and supplements and
things like that so people with
schizophrenia that's why
there's so many crazy people in
government
because they're nutritionally deficient
and so we can't help them if they won't
supplement and
we should
pass the law in congress that everybody
who's elected to whether it's a county
state
or federal government should be eating
taking supplementing with a healthy
brand and heart pack avoiding gluten
and eating three eggs three times a day
and then
people will make better decisions
and they'll be nicer
and they won't have so many divorces and
all this kind of stuff
i think to start dr wiley we need to get
a real food pyramid
that actually supports the body
in
in being healthy
because right now the food pyramid is
like upside down yeah it's way off it's
way way off because remember it's called
the food pyramid because it was invented
during the days of the egyptians
but it's like everything else it changes
but it seems like every time it changes
health gets worse dr williams yeah yeah
well it's going the wrong direction
because you have to appreciate that most
people who are nutritionists don't know
anything about nutrition
okay they are just parroting what
they're taught they really don't know
the basic biochemistry and this and the
other
we have the seven food groups
okay well that's what they're taught
they don't know anything about the
biochemistry and what it all means they
just say well this is what we're taught
this is what we're passing on
okay to the to the people we're trying
to educate
and so um we we have a long way to go
and so that's why
i spend so much time
talking about getting rid of the bad
foods
a lot of times you know i don't have
time to go into you know the thousands
of things that can go wrong if you're
eating the bad foods
i just like there's a thing going on now
with the pandemic boy they missed that
one by a thousand miles no i'll take
that back they missed that one by a
million miles
and instead of being a nothing bug
that you can wash your hands and wear a
mask and distance yourself and we're all
going to be gone in a couple weeks we
have
40 million 520 784 infections and 662
dead by this afternoon we'll have 663
000 dead
okay for a nothing bug
and so i just get breathless every time
i see these figures because it's only
going up right now
rebecca it's only going up and that's
because again the doctors are in this
rut
and they should be held responsible they
are responsible for this
uh in the beginning we had the ability
to nip this thing in the bud
but they treated it like a common cold
and
so
it is their fault we're in this mess up
to our eyeballs here
it has impacted the economy of the world
it certainly impact the economy of the
u.s uh there's so many people who lost
jobs
um and so forth um many many in fact
many of these fast food restaurants are
closing down
forever now we're not talking about one
restaurant we're talking about the whole
chains are going away
because they depended on people being at
work and coming there over lunch hour
and on getting their breakfast on their
way to work and all kinds of stuff
and they've lost that
for the last two years you can't not be
in business for two years and stay in
business and so
um these things are crashing down now
and everybody has to point their fingers
okay at doctors because they have missed
it so badly they keep looking for that
that magic drug they're looking for the
magic drug oh we got to have this new
antiviral
antibiotic
no
you need the 90 essential nutrients to
stay away from the bad food and then of
course you still need your colloidal
silver which has been
the antibiotic
for humanity for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years when penicillin
came along doctors love penicillin
because you need a prescription to get
it and you'd have to go to their office
and get a prescription and they charge
you for an office call and charge you
for the prescription all kinds of stuff
and they find some way to do an
examination or do some procedure on you
and pay for their kids tuition in
college
and so uh doctors are up to up their
eyeballs in this uh if criminals were to
have impacted the country
as negatively and as badly as the
medical system has they'd all be in jail
forever many of them would be executed
okay
yeah
it's definitely
um you know as a strange situation that
we're in
now dr willock i know this question is
going to come up and i know that our
best offense against disease whether
it's the virus whether it's
other things going on in the body that
you don't hear about it as much anymore
right now
but to protect ourselves
what is your
prescription your protocol that you
would recommend for somebody who's
wanting to protect themselves against
um
against the virus
okay protect against the virus you need
to eat a minimum of three meals a day
so you constantly have these nutrients
at a high level in your body
okay and again no gluten no wheat no
body ryan oats well can't we have just
one cheat day a month or something no
that's like say can i shoot myself in
the head once a month
no
absolutely no no cheat days
and i want you to eat three eggs twice a
day for an adult for a kid
even a newborn baby uh if the mother's
not gonna breastfeed that baby they're
going to be getting
um a formula enfamil similac and i'm the
guy i don't know if people remember this
but i'm the guy who got rid of
sizzicobros it's supposed to be a
genetic disease i'm the guy that got rid
of muscular dystrophy supposed to be a
genetic disease we gave the information
to jerry lewis he took it to the
mississippi association they fired jerry
lewis after he raised two billion
dollars for them
and so but i okay and then i also got
rid of sudden death syndrome which is
supposed to be the mothers laying on the
babies
that's how bright the doctors are okay
they were saying well the babies are
dying from sending the death syndrome
because the mothers are laying on the
babies because they're in bed together
it was all nonsense
um april 16 2013 we got a fda ruling
pushed on them by a federal court and
and they forced
um
they forced the infamous similac and all
these other baby farmers milk replacers
if you will
to
put these nutrients in there it was my
lawsuit that made that happen
and
by um the 19th of september
okay
february's was gone monster is
gone and in the front page of the
charlotte observer i mean we're talking
big thing like third world war stuff on
the front page of the charlotte observer
september 19 2014. we don't know why but
cinema death syndrome has vanished in
the state of north carolina
then three months later it came out we
don't know why
but sentiment death syndrome has
vanished in the state of
um missouri
we don't know why but son of a death
syndrome has vanished and so on
okay and so this is because
of these nutrients being forced by law
to be put into these baby farmers i had
been after them for 25 years
and the medical people kept saying no
don't don't do that there's no there's
no
science that says this and walk is a nut
and
um i wasn't a physician yet i was still
a veterinarian and so they went crazy
well
dr milan and i had been in china we did
1 700 autopsies on kids under the age of
10.
okay in in heilum zhong province and
keyshawn university
this area of china has the highest rate
of hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease anywhere in the world because
the nutrients are missing in the soil
okay
well
of those 1 700 35
died of
cystic fibrosis
minus those who had
um
had not at home died from it but they
all had muscular dystrophy 100
and then
almost 200 of them
under the age of 10 years of age died of
what would be diagnosed in the united
states is sediment death syndrome so we
took all that information we learned 1
700 autopsies and began to put this into
baby formulas and we got this published
okay in chinese and english
in the in the biology of trace animal
research
we got the klaus schwartz award for it
okay and was nominated for two nobel
prizes for it didn't get the nobel prize
but just the fact we were nominated was
just breathless and made you feel really
humble
but that's when all this good stuff
started happening when we put these
nutrients to the baby farms up until we
forced them to do that there was only
three
mineral nutrients out of the 60 there's
only three out of the 60 in the baby
formulas they were missing 57
and that's why they were having all
these birth defects and all these
children's problems including
schizophrenia and all this kind of stuff
going on
and gender issues that's when the gender
issue started
back in that time there was not a lot of
gender issues before that well at that
time when those baby farmers came out
with only three nutrients and they're
suddenly now
you know one out of every 10 babies born
with a gender issue
five out of ten babies are born with
schizophrenia
well and and i love the fact that you
know with having knowledge
moving forward it's something we can
prevent
right now
we support people to be the best that
they possibly can be
and in many cases a lot of those
symptoms go away because
of the body being supported through
nutrition
so yeah babies
yeah we actually have it's kind of like
the 90th century nutrients for infants
okay the kids tidy it's called
okay it's our it's our heavy-duty big
hammer if you will for infants this goes
into their baby formulas it's called
kids toddy and then you can't forget
the
efas right gotta have the efas for the
brain to work right and not to get blood
clots and stuff like that babies can get
blood cuts they don't get the efas so we
need both
and then
um
we also when they get to be old enough
you know they're six months old they're
starting to eat things
and chew on them we have the pollen
burst shoes and the efas this is
vitamins and minerals it's kind of like
a little chocolate shoe and
the efas in here come from sunflower
seeds
okay so it's very unique little product
for kids like a chocolate chew but it's
a very yummy mixed berry flavor it's
yeah well it has berries in it
absolutely there's like five different
berries in there
and some kids love it
it looks like a two
yes they do
i i just want to be clear it does not
take the place
of the kid's toddy no no no no no
this is just a healthy snack for kids
the kids toddy is the big hammer for the
kids every kid
in america
you know
certainly under 10 12 years of age they
should be taking the kids toddy and as
soon as you can get them to take the
healthy brain and heart pack you need to
move them in that direction
but a lot of them don't want to take
10 pills with a meal and that kind of
stuff and they fight you and they push
them under the table and stuff but they
love kids toddy it tastes good
and it gives them
88 you know the 90th cents of nutrients
the others you get in the efas they're
they can chew the efas a lot of kids
like to chew the aphas or you can
puncture the efas and squirt them into
the kids tidy and squirt them into the
baby formula
and we have the multi efa
that's much smaller that makes it for
the kiddos to swallow
that's a little piece yeah a little pea
size yeah little pea sized
yeah so i dr wellick i just love the
fact that we
where some people may may think oh you
have so much i just don't know where to
get started the fact that we have so
much to offer
were able to cater
to
a large variety of people
and meeting their needs and
that is something that i have been so
appreciative over
is having those different options to
offer people
yeah you hit the point and that's why we
that's why we have 5 000 products we
have 5 000 products rebecca 5 000 you
know so many of these nutrition
companies have three products okay we
have 5 000 products and this is so
everybody can pick and choose what they
want that fits their religious eating
requirements
okay or they just choose to be
um a vegan or whatever it is they want
to do
okay
we have the efas which is made from
seeds we have the efa pluses which are
made from fish i take
both of them okay i'm kind of hedging my
bed i take both
yeah
but if you're a vegan and you don't want
to take fish oil we have the efas which
are made from the efas from seeds and
again the pollen burst shoes
the efas come from sunflower seeds plant
material again
so we have a lot of choices
5 000 products
well okay so here's something that i
want to really
point out too with that many products
especially with their flagship products
dr wallach
they were formulated to synergistically
work together oh absolutely
you can go to the store and pick and
choose and cherry pick and
what you get
does not work together nor is it
absorbable
and that's one thing with the youngevity
products they are
formulated with all the car
factors the nutrients need so the body
can actually utilize and absorb the
nutrients within plus the products work
together
so which is something that i found
to probably be not probably
it was
what changed my life
thank you for sharing that rebecca
because you know
um i'm sure people you know look upon
you as okay well we can't trust wally
but rebecca we can trust her so that's
just a good thing
all right and then i do want to throw in
here also for kids um for dessert you
know at night time they can have
gluten-free ice cream think of
gluten-free ice cream and sprinkle the
kids sprinkles on top of it which is
vitamins and minerals it tastes like
watermelon i use these
kids sprinkles okay
on my gluten-free ice cream i have
gluten-free ice cream every night and
put the kids sprinkles on top of it so
everything i eat even my dessert
is heavily supplemented
and of course
i have my face mask in every room i have
my face mask in the car i have face
masks on you know every place that i'm
you know every room in the house
so that if somebody drops in
i can just grab a face mask and put it
on
so i don't have to worry about them
breathing on me um and when they leave
i'll you know throw my clothes into the
in the into the closed bed and jump in
the shower
very quick
and take some extra colloidal silver and
so forth you really have to be proactive
protect yourself otherwise you'll be
visiting
you know the the place where they
embalmed bodies
yeah well i'm not ready to go there
and there's no way no way i'm even close
to
to stepping on that banana peel
not a chance
unless the good lord calls me home early
but i plan on sticking around dr wallach
i think the good lord has plans for you
here on this earth for a long long time
because um you know people always ask
well how long do you think you're going
to live wallach well
at the very least
there are super centenarians have you
heard of super centenarians these are
people who are 110 years of age if you
reach 110 years ago you're considered a
super centenarian
and so at the very least i believe i
will be a super centenarian but i think
no i'm going to get much more than that
now methuselah lived to be
676 thousand of 676 years 676 years okay
okay
676 years
exactly
sometimes i wonder if their calendar was
the same as ours
but there was a lot of people during the
biblical days who did live to be 110 120
150 300
um i think even moses lived to be 300
okay and so these are things you know
were they did they not know math very
well and have the figures wrong are
those correct figures well let's give
them the benefit i don't think they're
correct figure because these were sort
of the
the the hand-picked people by the good
lord and he had missions for them so he
gave them extra life so he didn't have
to keep training new people
when he found a good one yeah when he
found a good one he wanted to keep him
right and so
um
and so at the very least
you know we we have something like a
hundred thousand people over the past
um hundred years in america who have
lived over a hundred
we only have 32 super centenarians who
live to be 110 and older and so we have
a little bit of work to do okay don't be
happy with a hundred go for 200 go for
300 go for 600
but but you're going to have to work at
it's got to be a priority you cannot be
flippant you cannot
just say oh i'm not going to take my
colloidal silver today oh i'm not going
to take my vitamins minerals today i'm
just going to go out and have you know
pizza on the on the wheat crust with my
buddies no
um i buy 25 gluten-free pizzas
the crust is made from cauliflower
okay and it has four cheeses on it like
eight different vegetables and i put two
hamburger patties on top i eat a half of
that pizza when i eat the pizza i put
hamburger patties on top of it
and
and so
um you know when the grandkids come over
and the kids come over they get pizza
they don't know that the crust is made
out of cauliflower they just know
they're getting pizza
now if i say we can't have pizza because
they've got a wheat crust
they'd never come over to see grandpa
okay but
boys
yeah it's uh it's it's pizza night oh
they all come running over
okay
and so i attract them by having food
that i know they like
but it's my way okay it's a gluten-free
pizza as opposed to just a pizza
from
um
pizza heaven restaurant and everything
is made out of wheat flour
absolutely absolutely well dr wallach um
thank you so much for that introduction
and for talking about mental health
and going into you know what we can do
to protect ourselves
and you know eating
you know we look at the way
people have eaten over the years and
we've got to get clues from that
information and use that information to
to improve our own health and keep
ourselves healthy so thank you for for
giving us a little bit of history there
appreciate that
now
i know that there are a lot of people on
here today
that were invited by somebody
specifically whether you're watching the
show live with us or you're watching the
replay and somebody shared the video
with you
if you have any questions please get
back with the person that shared this
program with you
they have a vested interest in making
sure that you get what you need
in order to optimize your health
we do have a store
on our website at askdoclive.com
that is available there for
anybody who has not spoken with somebody
about any of the youngevity products
before
and we also have if you use the contact
us we have a team of holistic health
coaches
that are there to answer your questions
so you can use that contact us and get
information
in regards to you specifically as well
but again get back with the person that
invited you to watch this show
we have a team also that is standing by
at eight five five nine four nine seven
two three four
of coaches that are available to help
you place orders if you have never
ordered it before
so
with that i know ann had her hand up and
do you still have a question
let me go ahead and
and go ahead you are unmuted thank you
um good morning doc
hello ann how can we help you
so i'm 60 years old that's six zero i'm
five foot six 129 pounds
um i've been following your program for
two months and i feel really good
um the best part is not feeling hungry
all the time and it's a lot easier to
reduce your calories when you're not
when you're not hungry okay now stop
there stop there for a second
when you're eating three minerals four
meals a day and you're still hungry
that's a behavior called pica p-i-c-a
and i
behavior is caused by very specific
mineral deficiencies and so the fact
that that pica that behavior has gone
away where you're not hungry all the
time anymore you're getting those
minerals and that's why that that's why
that pack of behavior has gone away but
i just want people to huh
yeah and it's awesome let me tell you
all right um so
what i just wanted to talk to you today
about was um i still have a little bit
of digestion issues i've had them
for years
my doctor said i had trouble absorbing
which is one of the reasons why i
switched over to your program
um i my digestion is a little slow i
feel
sleepy after i eat okay stop
stop
okay now if your digestion is in trouble
um are you still eating gluten are you
still eating wheat bread around oats
nope i i have not eaten gluten for years
okay good well just make sure everybody
in the household you cannot be cooking
for something you cannot make oatmeal
for somebody else right okay good
because you'll get cross-contaminated
now when you get sleepy after meals
do you have any idea what nutritional
deficiency that is it's a nutritional
deficiency it's called
reactive high glycemia you eat and then
a half hour hour later you go to sleep
that happens a lot in people you know
dinner time eat a big dinner uh you know
with a baked potato or a lot of you know
pizza crust or something like that or
noodles uh rice or whatever and then an
hour later they're asleep on the couch
i'm trying to watch television
um
you know this is called reactive
hyperglycemia it's actually caused by
deficiency of a very specific nutrient
there's actually two nutrient
deficiencies cause that
and so are you taking our sweeties
um no i'm not taking the sweeties i just
started on the ultimate enzyme so
okay well you need the sweeties are you
taking the healthy brain and heart pack
or the healthy start pack what are you
okay good now you want to add this you
don't want to add the sweeties uh get
yourself uh you weigh 140 pounds you say
129. 129. yeah i'd start out with two
bottles a month of the sweeties add that
to your program so you can take three of
those twice a day
and then once you stop falling asleep
after meals then you can cut it to
two twice a day instead of three twice a
day and then when it just totally stops
always just stay at that two
um twice a day okay of the sweeties
and so yeah i do i take three sweeties
twice a day i don't have any diabetes or
anything like that and
like i say i i
probably sleep
six hours
every 24 hours i sleep six hours but
it's not all at the same time i'll sleep
an hour and wake up and work for two
hours and i'll sleep for an hour too
then i work for a couple hours and and
so forth
and i apologize there's great grandkids
on the other side of the house making a
lot of noise with carts and things so i
apologize no problem
another thing i wanted to ask you is i
just bought a box of the daily digest
and um i just wanted to ask you when do
you think is the best time of day to
take that um and should i take it with
food or on an empty stomach
well you want to take it before you eat
okay
yeah any enzyme products you want to
take maybe say 10-15 minutes before you
eat
okay
all right um my other issue that i'm
having is um
my doctor had me on an estradiol patch
and natural progesterone cream and i
wanted to come off of that so i bought
the xerifm
but i'm still having hot flashes so i'm
thinking i was taking
one bottle so i was taking two a day so
i was thinking maybe that that's not
enough maybe i need more yeah i start
out with three twice a day of the xerifm
don't forget to eat your eggs because
you need the cholesterol uh estrogen is
95 by weight cholesterol
okay and your brain which you know works
on the sex side too uh needs 75 of its
weight is cholesterol so you need three
eggs twice a day even at 140 pounds you
need three eggs twice a day
uh you and i will weigh about the same i
weigh 142.
okay and so i i eat um
three eggs twice a day minimum sometimes
i'll eat nine eggs a day
but um depending on you know what i'm
gonna have going on and then i take uh
three of those zero tests
uh twice a day i take
three the zero test twice a day from n
okay
okay okay
all right and um my last question i have
is um i bought a bottle of the herbal
rainforest um because i have um heavy
metals i have lead and mercury
um and i was wondering when the best
when the best time of day to take that
and how often
i would take it three times a day
did you have a hair analysis
um
i actually i did a urine test
okay yeah once you get a hair analysis
you know you can
um
go into the book um
uh let's see here
uh um
where earth's forbidden cures yeah thank
you rare has been cures and it's chapter
10 yeah it tells you how to collect your
hair and where to ship it how to get the
hair analysis and that'll give you a
very accurate
um
look at how much lead and mercury and
uranium and all this kind of stuff you
have in you
because i never trust the urine test of
a doctor
okay
the question you have to ask a doctor
when he says you got these problems i
have one question doctor i say sure
what's your question what you want to do
is say do you have kids in college and
does tuition do
yeah
okay and so they're always going to find
some little thing you know were you did
you have one tenth of one percent
mercury did you you know you understand
what i'm saying yeah or
already have an amount of mercury in you
that's going to be significant
and so that's where hair analysis is
just absolutely so accurate
and um
uh
it tells you how to collect where to
ship it and how you know
how to package it and all that kind of
stuff okay
okay that sounds great
all right i think that'll do it for me
doc
okay well call us you know like in 30
days you can call us before that if you
want but you know call us in 30 days and
call us when you get the results of the
hearing analysis and so forth because
you're suffering from a lot of the
things that so many people do
and they are going to want to hear well
well how does she do okay and so because
they're going to want to hear from you
and these are toll-free numbers it
doesn't cost you anything but you're
going to be an angel of god and share
your story with a lot of people okay
all right i will thank you so much
god bless you and thank you very much
you too
thank you and
thank you thank you next dr wallach
let's go to nina
nina go ahead and unmute yourself
okay can you hear me yes mina
okay
yeah dr wallach i've been diagnosed with
something called
eosinophilic asthma
and i had already been diagnosed with
allergic asthma i've had that since
about five years of age and i was
wondering if your doctor should go to
jail
okay
i don't know how old are you i am i'm
72. i'm so you've had
so you've had asthma for 67 years
okay
and you should have only had it for six
months or less
okay asthma is very very easy disease to
get rid of it's a nutritional deficiency
and it's always secondary to gluten
gluten causes inflammation inflammation
causes eosinophils to come out they're
the white blood cells that deal with
inflammation
and so
um
do you have any skin plums any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis
i just started having that this year
okay
did you have any problems like irritable
bowel syndrome diverticulitis crohn's
disease celiac disease any of that kind
of stuff
no
okay did you ever have any um
gray hair
uh i used to yes
and your hair colors come back
uh partially i've been on something
called redox molecules
okay well if you're taking your 90
essential nutrients and staying away
from gluten that hair color will come
back completely because gray hair is not
an aging thing it's a
red warning light okay our gray warning
light here whatever you want to say but
it actually is due to a deficiency of a
nutrient whether you're supplementing
that nutri or not you'll be deficient if
you're eating gluten because you cannot
absorb it
okay
and the same deficiency
situation a different nutrient
will
cause asthma
and so um asthma
um you should be able to get rid of that
in 30 60 days if you get off i mean
totally totally totally totally
everybody in your household dog cat bird
fish spouse kids grandkids everybody in
the house you cannot go to restaurants
and sell gluten you know like spaghetti
factory and stuff like that pizza hut
you can't go to those places because
you're just swimming in gluten
okay
uh-huh
okay i've been a vegan for almost three
months now with no gluten and no flour
at all
and my asthma hasn't improved
well uh how how many eggs are you eating
well i'm a vegan so no eggs okay there's
no animals in an egg
the chick is that little white spot on
top of the oak you ever cracked a raw
egg and you see a little white spot on
top of the yolk that's the chick you can
take that off and the yolk and the white
of the egg there's no meat in it it's
not an animal
okay so when people say i'm a vegan
you're going to be in big trouble if
you're going to be vegan you need to be
an ovo lacto-pisco vegan
ovo means egg
lacto means
dairy
what's the first food
of a baby whale
a baby rhinoceros a baby human a baby
gorilla a baby kangaroo
a baby dog cat
elephant what's the first food
milk
can milk be bad only if you're eating
something bad it gets in the milk okay
so that's ovo lacto the egg and dairy
and then
ovolactopisco pisco is fish there's no
red meat in fish
there's no red meat and fish
there's no red meat and fish but it does
have essential fatty acids okay
it also has um great protein in the
muscle of the fish which is the fish
flesh
okay so if you're going to be a
successful vegan believe me these people
who were
60 70 80 years old oh yeah we're
successful vegans like you need to ask
them are you an ovo lacto pisco vegan
and they'll kind of get red a little bit
and hum and haw and say well yeah but
you know
i don't tell people about that part
okay
so you don't have to eat red meat you
don't have to eat chicken but eat the
egg
your brain needs cholesterol 75 percent
of your brain weight is cholesterol okay
your hormones are 95 percent
cholesterol
cholesterol does not block your arteries
it's fried foods
well how how can a vegan get blocked
arteries if they're not eating meat
well that's because they're frying
their wheat
[Laughter]
okay you got it
yes
okay then call us every yeah call us
every couple of weeks and give us a
progress report because you're going to
have a great great great story to share
with everybody
all right i'll do that thank you
god bless you
you too
thank you all right dr wallach we are so
close to the top of the hour let's go
ahead take five minutes right now and we
will be right back with more questions
and answers
from our audience thank you everybody
again for being here with us on askdoc
live we are here to be a resource to you
that empowers you to be able to make
choices on your own towards a better
health journey so dr wallach let's go
and be back in just a few
hello everybody i would just like to
make a request from our viewers um if
your camera is on and you are moving
around and
doing lots of things and you're carrying
your phone
with you um the
video can be very distracting and um
if you could just turn it off while
you're doing that otherwise i will be
turning off your videos so um
i just wanted you all to know that that
is a request that we are making today
and always thank you
all right i hope everybody got up and at
least stretched and got some hydration
in their body during that short little
break dr wallach will be back with us
here shortly and i just want to remind
all of you
that
you are
free thinking empowered individuals who
can make choices in regards to what goes
into your body and i know sometimes it's
hard we get those cravings
of wanting specific things well
from personal experience those cravings
are caused from nutritional deficiencies
when you
take care of those nutritional
deficiencies and you give your body
exactly what it needs
food choices become so much easier where
you can choose and let go things of the
past that you used to just indulge on
that were not benefiting your body
so i really encourage you at the minimum
get the 90 essential nutrients just to
support your body so that your
beyond surviving
and thriving
this program is a resource
for you we encourage you to share this
program with others as well
so that they too can get information in
regards to
another way of approaching health
because our food sources are depleted of
nutritional deficiencies
are depleted of nutrients rather
causing us to have nutritional
deficiencies
dr wallach had mentioned a little bit
ago you know
when
farming
basically they want a high yield
so they give the three nutrients that
are going to provide that high yield
well the
soil if the minerals are not in the soil
it's not going to be in the plants
and we're not going to get it in the
food
so we do need to be intentional on what
we put into our body and that includes
absorbable
nutrition
so i see that dr wallach is back welcome
back dr wallach
am i muted i think can you hear me
yes sir we can hear you loud and clear
and i have a qu couple questions here
that have been put into the comments
and the cat would like to know can good
nutrition and
eating the right foods help eliminate
inflammation
for instance
bursitis
yes
now bursitis is is a form of arthritis
the bursa are little sacs over the
joints that actually produce
joint fluid if you will okay to
lubricate the joints they're called
bursa
and they get inflamed when you're
missing nutrients
and they're kind of an early form of
arthritis
okay
it's just like the cartilage is going
away the bursa is getting inflamed
and so
this would be a perfect place for the
healthy bone and joint pack
the
msm
vitamin d3
are
uh flexi care plus plexi care plus okay
do all that and the bursitis thing will
go away immediately but if you want to
have some immediate relief you can put
topically on top of it our cm cream our
trauma oil
and you know like in three to five
minutes the pain will go away for maybe
an hour or two
uh but after a couple of days you won't
even need to put the trauma oil and the
cm cream on anymore because once things
heal
the pain is gone
awesome and you know food
can be
greatly inflammatory
so we definitely need to make sure that
we're sticking with the good foods list
dr wallach and removing
you get an a plus because no fried foods
no fried foods no fried foods okay of
any kind and then absolutely because
they cause
they cause inflammation
not only in the intestines in the
stomach but also in the rest of the body
also
and so um
and when they cause all this
inflammation it reduces your efficiency
of absorption in your intestines because
usually when people fry things they'll
roll chicken and wheat flour
to get a kind of a crust on the fried
chicken right
so you're getting a double wham either
you're getting the gluten and you're
getting the negative of the frying pan
well and and so think about this folks
when we fry stuff we're taking it to
temperatures the molecules were not
designed
to function at and it's converting those
molecules so you've got that chemical
reaction there that is not designed for
consumption of the body
so
yeah fried foods could be good it's a
fast way to cook things you know you
i myself when i go past a restaurant
that's frying stuff got my stomach turns
doctor wallach
it it's just the smell yeah
just the smell of it
um
which
it used to be
you know the fry thing smelled good but
now that my body is just not wanting
those things because it's not starving
it just i have no no drop out towards it
and i think that's probably
yeah you don't have pika anymore
no
not at all
well let's go to
the next question and she actually has
her hand up now so thank you
for raising your hand go ahead and
unmute yourself
hi doc
i'm 56 years old
okay wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute you're talking down
and so
she has to kind of look up a little bit
so i can hear you okay
okay i'm five foot that's better okay
206 pounds
i'm obese obviously my cholesterol came
back at 287 for the total hdl was 96.
with an hdl ratio of 33
triglycerides were 87 and ldl 174
doctor suggested medication
okay now first of all
um do you have any other issues do you
have high blood pressure diabetes
no no no issues just the cholesterol and
the result and and the obesity okay so
you don't have any skin problem no skin
problems not at all no do you have any
gray hair
a few
okay how old are you
is that 56 or 66 56 five six five six
okay do you have any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea irritable bowel
syndrome celiac disease anything like
that no issues
no eye issues do you have any wringing
in your ears do you have any ringing in
your ears
no ringing in the ears nothing
any balance problems
no balance issues
okay do you have any noisy joints did
your knees pop and crack when you go
upstairs or anything like that
no sometimes every now and then they may
ache a little bit not a lot
okay not a lot but a little bit of a
knee issue okay
all right okay well it you know it um
let's see here
uh 56 years old you're bound to have a
few things going on
a little bit of white hair that tells me
a lot thank you and again
when somebody who's five foot six you
should weigh about for a lady i'd like
to see what about 140
um kind of thing and you weigh 206 so
you're 65 maybe 70 pounds overweight all
right
so what i want you to do is get our
you're going to have to get three boxes
of our
um
let's see here
our
keto caramel bars there's only ten in a
box so you need to get three boxes so
you have one per day it doesn't have to
be the same meal every day you can have
one for breakfast today tomorrow could
be lunch you have three days in a row
it'll be for dinner you know
but you need
one keto caramel bar
per day to replace a meal well then i
want you to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat by rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
drinks got to go
all right
and then at um 206 pounds i want you to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
for months two healthy brain and heart
pattern month to full dose everything
twice a day
and then i want you to get our msm
take two bottles a month to the msm so
you can take three with breakfast three
with a lunchroom dinner it will support
healthy skin healthy bones healthy
cartilage
and when i say healthy bones that
includes the bone marrow where your
white blood cells
and your antibodies and all that kind of
stuff are formed so it's very important
to keep your bone marrow happy right
and
by getting rid of all the fried foods
and gluten the cholesterol levels will
come down and the ratios
of
various forms of cholesterol will be
corrected
you got you know you say knee issues one
smallie pop and crack maybe you're
saying the other
and do you ever have any low back stuff
do you ever have any low back issues
no
okay good excellent
all right so let's let's start here
and uh obviously
um if you do any exercise even walking
around the block you want to use our
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it it has 75 minerals and
25 vitamins amino acids
uh a girl your size you could take two
of those rebounds a day uh comes in cans
or and it also comes in these little
uh sticks there's 30 of these sticks in
a in a box and you can tear open the top
or cut the top off of the scissors and
dump it into
you know a bottle of water
and sip on that
so two of our rebounds a day
that'll give you energy and so forth and
give you nutrients
so that your cravings your hunger will
go away it will help with weight loss
also
your hair color will come back
because that's not an age thing it's
actually a nutritional deficiency that
causes white grain silver here
and so then give us a call every couple
weeks let us know how much you weigh let
us know what's going on with your hair
let us know what's going on with your
knees and so on
and then when you go to the doctor and
you get some another blood test let us
know what's going on there okay
okay
okay god bless
all right
thank you elizabeth
okay dr wellick you've got a comment in
the or a question in the comments from
rod now rod is 48 years old five foot
eight
um
275 or 235 rather
but
very muscular so he is he is a
bodybuilder and he wants to know
um as a black man his blood pressure is
not coming down quick enough what can he
do to help with blood pressure
okay
well first of all he's got to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth right notes no sugar
and then um i want him to have a 235
pounds i want him to have two healthy
brain and heart packs a month to full
dose everything twice a day i want him
to get two bottles a month of our msm so
we can take three of those with each
meal and they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between vertebrae bone makes bone
itself especially if he's a bodybuilder
he's putting a lot of pressure on his
joints and bones and discs
and so on
and then i want him to have three of our
ultimate daily classic tablets three
times a day three at breakfast treat
lunch for dinner time
and
high blood pressure is not a genetic
thing in black people but it is common
in black people because of their dietary
habits
okay and so he needs three of those
um
healthy
let's see it's gonna be the ultimate
ultimate dailies okay
he needs a three three times three three
times he has three bottles a month
ultimate daily classics
and his blood pressure will come down
very rapidly usually within two to six
weeks he'll be all down in the normal
range but he has to stay on that for a
couple of months even though blood
pressure came down now stay on that for
a couple of months and then after a
couple of months cut it down to three
twice today for a maintenance
right now i'm going to take three three
times a day to deal with the problem
um that he's concerned about
but um and of course
uh i want him also
uh to be because he's got things that
have put him at risk
of the covet i want him to take the
colloidal silver
um
don't forget the the colloidal silver
don't forget our hand sanitizer
especially in the gym if he's working
out at the gym and you know there's a
lot of people there and um sweat flying
around
and so
um
he needs to be really really careful
with contact and picking up something
that somebody else picked up you know
like a barbell kind of thing
um
or doing chin-ups on a chin-up bar and
so forth that somebody else was just
there and i when i go to those places i
like to wipe those bars off you know
with my hand sanitizer
before i use them
well now dr wellick let's talk about
stress
how does stress
in addition to the physical stress from
bodybuilding how does stress from things
going on around you affect blood
pressure
okay well stress of course
causes your adrenal glands release
hormones
okay stress that's why you have adrenal
glands and your adrenal glands will
release hormones which makes your heart
beat faster so you can run away from
whatever the stress is right um
it helps you release antibodies to
protect you against bugs
um it actually
helps you
um
what should i say it makes your body get
ready to run
away or stand and fight
and so
that's what stress does to you
but if you take your 90th century
nutrition stay away from the bad foods
take your um
uh
i i like understand
situations of stress she's used a
healthy brain heart pack and then don't
forget
okay don't forget this um
let's see the flexi care plus flexicare
i got to get it right flexi care plus
okay
that is very very good for your bones
and joints and
bone marrow tendons ligaments connective
tissue skin arteries veins don't forget
the efas
i take three fas
minimum of three twice a day and three
if a pluses twice a day it's the minimum
sometimes i'll if i'm
driving or going someplace or flying
i'll take three three times a day so i
don't get blood clots and that kind of
thing and so
you can
be like a conductor of an orchestra and
when it's time for the strings to play
you point to them when it's time for the
for the trumpets to play you point to
them and it's that kind of thing same
way um what you need uh when you're
flying
from san diego california to washington
dc is different on a day than when
you're staying at home bouncing your
grandkid on your knee okay
and so you have to be able to
orchestrate that that's a good term to
throw and orchestrate your nutrients and
this is why
we have these books so you want to get a
hold of the book epigenetics the death
of the genetic theory disease
transmission you want to get a hold of
my newest book i don't know
um it's flying off the shelf like crazy
the newest book here
um
okay dr wallace cooking without the bad
foods is 300 pages of gluten-free
recipes 300 pages of gluten-free recipes
doctor while he's cooking without the
bad foods okay if you get ten of them
there's a discount
okay if you get a case there's a bigger
discount and so on obviously but that's
true of all of our books
and i also uh want to
um get a hold of that what we call the
quintetta books
they're five books let's play doctor
okay let's be herbal doctor passport
chromotherapy
um dead doctors don't lie it's all in
your head
um doctor walks uh cooking without the
bad foods but dead doctors don't lie the
book is in two languages
the
um cd is in nine languages
and so it's a great way to introduce
people from other countries and other
states
to
to what we do
um it's definitely
there's over the cd
uh there's over 700 million in
circulation now we put that many in
circulation 700 million
okay in circulation of the cd dead
doctors and lights in nine languages
that's fantastic i love the fact dr
wallach that
you are so intentional in
reaching
everybody
well that's our goal i i think we've
been given we've been given a mission by
the good lord and i can't thank you
enough for participating uh you and your
team are angels of god and so i just
appreciate all that you do and you and
your team
does
and so um
you are definitely
um
on the team
well it's an honor for us to be here
and to share you
with the world
it really is a true honor so we
appreciate that we appreciate you taking
time out of your schedule
but we're not over yet folks
so we've got more questions here
and let's go to
hemet hemet go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hello dr holish how are you
okay how can we help you
so i am 40 years old
my weight is 90 kg
and my heart okay wait a minute okay so
okay so that's about 200 pounds okay
yeah
height is 163 centimeter about 5.4
okay
and i have hypothyroidism
i have two boys one is eleven one is
five i wanna plan one more baby what
should i do okay
okay
where are you from
canada
oh you don't have a canadian accent
where are you from
india
india ah okay
now now i believe you okay
[Laughter]
okay
very good okay now what you need to do
is get rid of all the bad foods
okay get rid of all the bad foods
and of course india is a very
interesting
uh country
um
yeah but i live in canada right now i i
know
but your background is from india so i'm
just saying india is a very interesting
country
um
yeah
okay
um so anyway
uh i want you to um
are you eating like a canadian or are
you eating like
people from india
india
okay so you're still in india
[Laughter]
so yeah your body is still in india if
you're eating you know foods you go to
the grocery store and you're buying food
from india there's a lot of people from
india in canada okay
the british empire
actually
dealt with india for many many years 100
years
yeah
and
they
occupied india they occupied india for
100 years in northern india in the
northern nine states right
of india
there's southern there's 20 southern
states and seven territories in india
now the okay now the northern nine
states
they have
um 95 of the deaths from covid
in in india the southern 20 states and
seven territories only have five percent
of the deaths
and the northern nine states have
um 87 of the infections of covet and the
southern 20 states
and the
seven territories only have 13 percent
of the infections why is it a huge
difference well for a hundred years
india was occupied by great britain they
taught the northern united states how to
grow wheat right around oats and how to
eat wheat broth around oats and so they
eat more like europeans whereas the
people in the south
eat more like
historically you know india with rice
soup yeah
follow your advice
we don't eat
gluten
okay good no gluten now at 200 pounds
i want you to get get rid of the bad
foods no fried foods
okay no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no gluten no wheat no butter i
know no sugar no carbonated drinks
and no no cruciferous vegetables because
you have a thyroid issue no cruciferous
vegetables you go back to them when your
thyroid is happy but not yet
right now you want to get off the
cruciferous vegetables we're talking
about
broccoli cauliflower cabbage
and that sort of stuff that's got to go
kale all those things got to go
then i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart packs per month two
healthy brain heart pattern about the
full dose everything twice a day
and i want you to take one keto meal a
day at five foot four i'd like to see a
weigh 140 you need to lose about 60
pounds so i want you to have one keto
meal a day you're going to need to get
three boxes of our keto caramel bars
there's only 10 in a box so i want you
to take one meal a day a keto bar
and then i also want you to add
to this program
um our um
we have several different thyroid
products okay
and i want you to take three of those
twice a day
okay
uh
i like our fucoid z you can take a few
coins z take three of those twice a day
you can take our oceans gold through
those twice a day
and um
that will help your thyroid get back to
normal but stay away from stay away from
the bad foods
okay and then call us every couple of
weeks let us know how much to weigh
and um you're gonna you're gonna have a
good story you're gonna share your good
story and you know this is a toll-free
so it doesn't cost you any money
to call us
and so we'd love to hear your story and
your story will help a lot of people
because you're going to have a very very
good result when you get down to about
150 pounds
uh then you can start thinking about
having a you know another healthy baby
okay
okay dr thank you
you're gonna have to teach me
how to speak in the in the basic um
languages of india
[Laughter]
bye bye
bye
fantastic thank you so much
now dr wallach the next question i have
is coming in
um
we have a lady she's 50 years old
5 foot 2 inches
142 pounds
and she has a condition called hydrogen
titus
[Music]
which okay so i looked this up and
forgive me for totally butchering that
but it's a condition where there's lumps
that develop in areas where your skin
rubs together such as armpits groins
buttocks and breasts
and they are very very painful
they heal slowly and can lead to tunnels
under the skin and scarring
okay
uh i i apologize i didn't get the age of
this person
fifty
five zero
okay i cuz i thought you said fifteen
okay yeah okay
all right
so uh this person needs to get off all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brother ryan oats no sugar no
carbonated drinks even even the
the um
giant ones need to go because it's the
carbonation i'm concerned about as well
as the sugar
and then
at 142 pounds in this particular issue i
wanted her to have
two healthy abandoned heart packs per
month two health brand hard packs per
month two bottles of the msm per month
so you can take three of those three
times a day and they deal with
connective tissue two thirds of the
thickness of skin is connective tissue
all right
as well as artery walls and vein walls
and tendons and ligaments and
that sort of stuff
now
i wonder also to have three of our
hair skin and nails
i want to have three of those three
times a day it'll be three bottles a
month of hair skin and nails
i also wanted to have
the um
let's see here i'd have her take
the xerifm
xerifema
okay i'd have to take three of those a
day that'll be one bottle a month of the
xerifam that's going to help her with
hormonal issues but the skin thing the
hair skin and nails three of those three
times a day
and the msm
three of those three times a day which
is gonna deal with the connective tissue
in the skin
um and again she's away from all the bad
foods and then contact us every couple
of weeks
because these lumps and bumps where
their skin rubbing against skin
and there's tunnels and things which
could be sweat glands or oil glands or
whatever
um dilating
um so we need a little more information
there but any rate um
let's uh have her call us uh i'm sure a
doctor is a medical doctor's approach
that would be to give her cortisone and
prednisone and that kind of
stuff
which can deal with symptoms
but won't get down to the basic root
cause here which is definitely a
nutritional deficiency that's impacting
connective tissue in the body and if we
were to ask her i'll bet she has a back
problem or she's got joint problems um
she may
um you know have
blood pressure and diabetes problems a
lot of people well i'm on insulin my
diabetes is controlled i'm on blood
pressure medication my blood pressure is
under control the only thing i still
have issues with is my skin issue and so
they never bring up the things they have
under control because they think that's
all that can be done for it
so let's go those directions and then
let's hear from her every couple of
weeks or any time she goes to the doctor
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallach
and next we have a gentleman
he's 67 years old
and we're going to be dosing per 100
pounds i don't have an exact weight
um 400 for weight 400 pounds no no we
don't know what
weight is so we're just going to dose
recommendations
yep
he has diabetes and arthritis
that's his diagnosis
uh kneecaps are badly damaged they're
saying the only cure is surgery and
there are times where he can't even walk
or stand up
did we get a weight no so we're going to
go for the per 100 pounds
per hundred pounds okay so we got knees
we got arthritis we got diabetes did he
say anything about blood pressure or
weight no no does not say anything about
blood pressure or weight
okay
all right so let's go for a hundred
pounds of body weight gotta give you all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no gluten no
wheat broth rhinos no sugar i want them
to have
um per 100 pounds of body weight i want
them to have
unhealthy brain and heart pack per month
i also want them to have
two bottles a month of the msm so i can
take three uh with each meal per hundred
pounds of body weight
and um
then
for the diabetes he's got to stay away
from all the bad foods including sugar
right
and um
as the blood sugar comes down he can
reduce his medication if he's on
medication don't cold turkey off the
medication but as the blood blood sugar
goes down he can slowly reduce his
medication usually it takes about
anywhere from two weeks to uh 60 days
to get rid of diabetes i don't care if
they've had diabetes type 2 updates for
40 years it'll go very quickly
all right
arthritis is very easy to
repair and prevent it's not a genetic
thing it's not an autoimmune thing
it's the basic arthritis even rheumatoid
arthritis is due to nutritional
deficiencies with a secondary infection
of a bug called mycoplasma which is
killable with an antibody called
menocycline
and so
we need to hear from this guy a regular
basis but his knees
and his arthritis everywhere else his
body will
uh
repair 100
the diabetes should go away 100
and you know he needs to contact us and
give us more information we can speed up
the process but we're going with what we
got
you're muted back on
so i guess the question can you hear me
back better now
now i can hear you
[Laughter]
all right um thank you so much dr
wallach for that information
let's go to captain sam who has his hand
up
sam go ahead you are on live with dr
wallach hey that quality great to be
here thank you
okay
yep definitely been keeping the immune
system strong we've been having so much
sunshine these last month and a half two
months i've been getting sun every day
question i have does the
gluten affect the animals the same way
around here everybody's feeding the
wildlife bread and all that kind of
stuff and
then i got one more question after that
how does it affect the dogs the raccoons
and the birds
the same exact way it affects people
that's what i thought okay that's what i
thought yeah if you have intestines you
eat gluten you're in trouble okay same
way i figured even the birds even the
birds
even the birds you're murdering the
i love hummingbirds i'll give them
gluten
yeah i know people don't know here my
god yeah we got so many so many birds
over here where i'm at by the way
you're from canada right well no no i'm
i'm i'm in from chicago but i'm living
at the southern tip of lake michigan
okay so i can walk to the you know three
minutes there's sand dunes there's beach
there's water there's a lot of parks and
wildlife
you know i worked yeah yeah i worked at
the brookfield zoo for many years and so
i know one of my favorite places yeah i
i know uh the chicago area very well
lincoln park zoo yeah that's the best in
the world in my opinion still
okay it still is i love i love it been
going there since so you say you're old
enough to remember marlon perkins in the
link you better you ever believe i do oh
yeah i used to watch that show every
week yeah i i i saw you on there i'm
sure i did right yeah
how are you doing i worked with you in
renaissance i worked with him i i yeah
for we we caught many many white rack i
caught i personally caught 200 white
rhino and i have to thank you for
bringing that up because
uh back when i was
over there and perkins got me that
project to go work in in south africa on
the white rhino project and i'm flossy
and shishlui game parks and i caught 200
there's only 475 left back then that was
we're talking about
1965 to 67 okay i was there
and um
i caught 200 and brought them back
they're all scattered around the zoos
and um
right now there's 21 000 there
because we built three wild animal parks
just for the white rhino and we set up
all kinds of laws
and we put out the trace mineral salt
blocks for them
and so
it was a big project
and so that's one where we saved the
white rhino we're very so i just get
breathless every time i think about that
they were that close there was only 475
left and now there's 21 000 i remember
so we're hearing about that as a as a
young kid uh yeah god bless your heart
bless your heart your true hero of the
world i i believe that 100
all right now here's another question
sharks
yeah well i'm just being true sharks do
from what i hear and understand that i'm
i love diving and scuba diving and i've
seen a lot of sharks
how come they don't get any diseases at
all is that or is that is that true
it's not true they do yeah no no they do
get disease and of course i worked a lot
for the shed aquarium okay right right
okay
and
one of my first things when i when i got
off the plane from coming back from
africa to work on my big project um
using some of my papers perkins got a 25
million dollar grant from nih right this
i did 20 000 autopsies based on that
project
and that's
my my book is in the smithsonian
institute as a national session yeah
it's it was 5 000 pages they edited it
down
the textbook down to 1200 pages
okay very proud of that and so but um
the all of their um
um
let's see here
their whales and dolphins
uh were dying of congestive heart
failure right
okay they were feeding them smelled
which is a fish that has an enzyme in
there that dissolves
uh b vitamins particularly thiamin which
causes thymine deficiency causes
congestive heart failure so we changed
them over to herring and we stuffed all
these herring full of multivitamins and
b complex and extra b1 and in two weeks
time
all the dolphins and and porpoises and
whales stopped dying congestive heart
failure uh all the bears uh uh he's just
picking me up at the airport he's
telling me this he says all the bears
and all the zoos are dying of liver
cancer and all the geneticists are
saying it's a genetic thing in bears but
nobody knew about it because they're
dying in the woods and the coyotes are
eating them before he found them
absolutely right yeah yeah whacked out
thinking but that's how those guys are
yeah right okay okay so okay so all the
bears are dying all the bears are dying
of cancer i said what are you feeding
them he says well they're big and so we
give them you know we give each of them
like five loaves of bread a day and you
know a handful of fish i said what kind
of bread you give him he said well we
get it from a from the thrift store
because it's only 25 cents
a loaf i said well do they ever have
mold on them he said oh yeah they all
have bread mold them so we just take
those three or four slices and throw
them away and give them
i said well
there's ample
that comes from aspergillus mold on
bread that's the bread mole called
aspergillus it produces a toxin called
aflatoxin which causes liver cancer
let's put all the bears in the zoos on
dry dog food which they did it was
actually my first
written article for the zoo industry um
and it was in the international zoo
yearbook
and within six months time all the bears
stopped dying from liver cancer because
they switched them over to dog food
wow so so
fantastic so it's a myth then when i
read that sharks do not get diseases
then because they that's correct kind of
yeah
because because when they die when they
die their
buddy eats them
right yeah right right
so they don't see they don't you know
people don't see a dead shark floating
on top of the water and they take it in
and somebody does an autopsy and so but
you know i'm doing autopsies of animals
that are dying in
the um shed aquarium and other in the
zoos and so forth so i'm seeing all this
stuff that nobody else is seeing
and so there's so much misinformation so
much misinformation it just makes you
want to cry
and so this is why we're so glad and
this is why we actually started our
company to make sure that everybody at
least got the information they had their
choices
um and uh it's working we're saving
people we're saving countries we're
saving um whole groups i mean we're
saving
animals like the white rhino i mean how
how often do you get a chance to save a
whole species of animals like that
what a privilege what a privilege yeah
right
yeah thank you
thank you thank you thank you everybody
thank you camden sam
all right so dr wallach since we
are on the topic of animals we've got a
few questions here here um still related
to animals so we have a lady
we have a lady who has several community
kittens and cats and dogs
and one of the questions she
has is in regards to fip
which is a viral disease of cats caused
by a certain strain of virus called a
feline coronavirus
fip being for those of you who are
listening
phenyl
or feline sorry feline infectious
periotonitis peritonitis peritonitis
which is which is the
the puritan
is the
the lining of the body cavity
of the body cavity so she has a lot of
um cats that she's been feeding
that has have been diagnosed with this
so dr wellick what does she need to add
to what she's giving them colloidal
silver for those of you colloidal silver
kills all viruses
and would she
so with them being
wild community
okay she put them in the water just put
it in there yeah just put in their
drinking water or put it in their food
uh you you want to shoot for
if you can't grab them and put it down
their throat you're just going to put in
their drinking water
kind of watch it for a couple of days
and see how much water each one of them
drinks
and your goal for say
a five pound cat would be to get say
uh two or three or four drops for the
cold silver in them say twice a day
and so in a say in a pint of water
i'd put a couple of droppers full on the
coil of silver in there
so droppers not drops right
well in a pint of water i put a couple
of two droppers full and because i can't
see i can drink a pint of water
right okay perfect and the next question
has to do with
dogs
so 38 pound dog has a cyst
on the underside the veterinarian said
doesn't need to be removed as it's not
impacting anything but it keeps growing
bigger
it's the size of a ping-pong ball
so what can she give of the dog to help
with a cyst
of course we don't okay
well in addition
in addition to the dog food i would add
our minerals you know just the liquid
plant minerals to the drinking water a
38 pound dog
should be getting
maybe a um
let's see here a teaspoon of our plant
minerals
and if if it's a dog she can grab and
you know it's her pet so she can you
know put it in the dog's mouth every day
so she knows she's getting it or getting
it or if you can try putting on the food
and if the dog eats the food with the
plant minerals on it no problem
but you want to get at least a teaspoon
in
once or twice a day
of our plant minerals
and wouldn't hurt to put to two tablets
of the msm in there
excuse me which is good for
connective tissue including the skin and
it wouldn't hurt to throw in say two
of the capsules of the hair skin and
nails also
let's go that direction first
all right thank you dr wellick you know
i know a lot of us have our pets and we
care about our pets sometimes more than
we care about ourselves
so we want to make sure that
you
as the owner and caregiver of these pets
are getting what you need as well
because if you're not there who's going
to be taking care of them
and that well said
well said with everybody in our families
because i know
and this this really
hurts me dr wallet because i've had so
many
people call in and they're getting
products for their loved ones and i keep
saying well what are you taking what are
you taking
and i called to follow up to find out a
few days
earlier
the caregiver died of a heart attack
they had not taken this up didn't take
but the person they were caring for was
doing fabulous
and now having to deal with that loss
so
folks it is so so important
that you
as a caregiver whether you're a mom
you're a dad
taking care of children taking care of
your parents
you have a friend
or a friend
you have to take care of yourself
and value your own
just as much and and rebecca you hit the
nail on the head
and you hear heard me at the beginning
of the show
that um
i don't want to add 25 to 50 healthy
years everybody's life we have the
capacity to do this just like
um if you if you don't put oil in your
car
let's say you put water in the car
instead of oil and save some money
are you going to get the same mileage
out of that car if you as if you put oil
in there no
okay what if you put dirt from texas in
there because it's only 10 cents a quart
from dirt to texas there's bound to be
some oil in it if you're going to take
this dirt from texas would you get the
same mileage you would if you put you
know six quarts of high quality oil and
of course not and so
it's you know you're talking about
three to five bucks a day
and if you get rid of the bad foods
you'll save more than that amount of
money every day just by getting rid of
the bad foods because bad foods tend to
be expensive
um and that's not counting the cost of
your health care
okay but i'm just saying the cost of the
food is expensive and if you get rid of
all the bad foods and go to the good
stuff
um
and you don't have picas you're not
eating all day and gaining all that
extra weight you'll save an enormous
amount of money let's say you're saving
uh 20 bucks a day
and it's costing you five bucks a day
for your supplements
duh
that's a no-brainer
so my my supplements that i take every
month dr wallach
are less than what i would go to the
doctor and pay
cash
for a wellness check
oh yeah
absolutely and to have that wellness
check and then tell me that there's
nothing wrong with me now
is a fabulous feeling i love it what's
it done what's the doctor saying did the
doctor ask you what you're doing
this doctor just no
they always say whatever you're doing
keep doing it
yeah yeah
and it's yeah so they didn't know me
when i was at my worst
um so they don't haven't seen that
change but i've i've got pictures to
prove it and it's
i love where i am now
i love it yeah but that's usually well
that's usually what doctors say when
they see you and they say gosh you've
lost 300 pounds whatever you're doing
keep it up they never say what are you
doing let's sit down and talk about this
because i got some other obese people i
need to deal with i don't know what you
did were so successful they they don't
do that they just say keep doing what
you're doing bye next question
right yeah they didn't make any money
off of me getting healthy that's for
sure
all right so the next question dr
wallach um is from a beautiful woman at
the age of 71
she weighs
175 pounds at 5 foot she has been losing
weight
but she wants to know what she can do to
get rid of age spots
gray hair and
ringing in the ears
okay
well ringing the ears is tonight it says
caused by osteoporosis of the skull the
skull is squeezing the auditory branch
of the eighth cranial nerve the odds are
she's got other symptoms she may have
lost her
sense of smell as uh that's cranial
nerve number one olfactory nerve she may
also have
um
ona optic nerve atrophy where there's
cranial nerve number two
okay where the brain is the skull is
squeezing that the optic nerve
and the optic artery and the optic vein
and so there's lots of stuff happening
in the eye
and going to the eye doctors and getting
new glasses every six months and
everything but it's really honestly
approaches to the skull when you have
osteoporosis of the skull you've got
osteoporosis of your pelvis and the
vertebrae in your arms and your legs and
your neck and so forth
and so this gal here at 175 pounds she's
getting rid of all the bad foods
um no no fried foods that'll help with
age spots getting rid of the
age spots are not really age sponsored
due to
um
the
fried foods causing damage to the skin
okay the skin is trying to
save itself by putting out these
pigments to try and protect itself maybe
it's maybe your skin thinks it's a
sunshine okay
anyway
so um at
175 pounds
it needs to don't forget to get rid of
all the bad foods uh no fried food no
processed meats no oils no glutens and
wheat bread rhinos no sugar no
carbohydrate drinks even the diet one's
got to go two healthy brain heart packs
uh per month full dose everything twice
a day
um
she'll know she's absorbing when her
hair color begins to come back
but because she's got osteoporosis at
least to the skull if you got into the
skull you got it everywhere else too
she needs in addition to the two healthy
brain and heart packs i wanted to have
two bottles of vitamin d3 so you take
three of those twice a day so you can
absorb calcium and other nutrients and
put them in the right places
i wanted to have
a lady i'd never take one bottle a month
of our msm so we can take three of those
twice a day and that'll support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the rubbery bone matrix which
includes the skull
okay
and
usually i like to ask them do you have
anything going on in your hands and
wrists yeah my doctor said they have
carpal tunnel syndrome because they have
numbness in my hands no it's the skull
squeezing the spinal cord this is coming
out of the back of the skull
most people forget that your spinal cord
is not formed in your back is farming
your skull and your brain comes out of
the back of the skull through a big hole
called foramen magnum which is latin for
big hole okay and
and um
as soon as the skull begins to heal
that foramen magnum gets back to its
normal size takes the pressure off of
the
um spinal cord and so there's no need
for surgery in the wrist
anymore
isn't that funny that
it's not funny it's fabulous dr wallach
worked for you fabulous it worked for me
yes it did
so all right so oh goodness we're coming
up we only have 10 minutes left and a
lot of questions still
so here we have a woman
um we just addressed the ringing in the
ears but she's also having
problems with sleeping staying asleep
getting to sleep she's only sleeping two
hours she said
a total last week was only two hours
so what can she add to a protocol
um of course we
know the brain heart pack we want to
make sure that she's getting this out
did she did she tell us how much she
weighs
she did not
okay we'll go buy a hundred pounds of
body weight then uh get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no we brought
rhinos no sugar no carbonated drinks i
wanted to have per hundred pounds of
body weight one healthy brain and heart
fat per month i want her uh you know
half of those twice a day i also wanted
her to get it per hundred pounds of body
weight to get an extra bottle of
selenium not from walgreens arsene has
five cofactors in there what she needs
um
i want her to have um suppose she can
take three of our selenium twice a day
if she only weighs 100 pounds
and then um i want her also
to take the
glucogel i want her to take
uh
let's see here five of those
well let's take three twice a day for a
hundred pounds of body weight three
twice a day for 100 pounds of body
weight for our glucogen we have the
that's capsules if she prefers the
liquid she can get one quart of our
liquid per month glucagon take a half
ounce of that twice a day okay that'll
help with connective tissue and the bone
matrix and all that kind of stuff take
the pressure off the auditory branch of
the atrial nerve and the tinnitus will
go away
the sleep issue um
we want her
a half hour before bedtime
um
to take
of course i want her to take uh an extra
dose of calcium a half hour before sleep
time uh take um
take an ounce of calcium we also have i
believe it's called sleep effects
and the calcium can be the cal toddy
right doctor yeah yeah cal toddy there
you go calc toddy has got vitamin d3 and
some collagen in there too in the
calzotti
take those things a half hour before
bedtime
and um
you know don't drink coffee after three
o'clock in the afternoon a lot of times
you know they're at work and they're
drinking coffee all day they'll be
drinking coffee every hour throughout
the day
and uh so they have
a
a a
calcium issue okay they've got a sleep
issue because they've got a calcium
issue because they're
taking all this
gluten and so
a lot of times
you follow them around and you see
they're having drinking coffee every
hour and wondering why they can't get to
sleep at night okay
well and in addition to that coffee dr
warhook i know that soda pop with the
carbonation
absorption of calcium well yeah
cut it out
um also a recommendation i make that
helps a lot of people dr wallach is
making sure you don't take your beyond
tangy tangerine after two o'clock in the
afternoon
drink it through the morning because it
has all those vitamins
that the body needs
that for some people
you know well most people you get
amazing it makes them hyper yeah yeah
exactly
i just love the energy
that i get that goes all day long
and it's fabulous
all right let's get to um
one more hand here
and i wish we had a little more time
um
but now we need to do this real quick so
we have a gentleman a male 5 foot nine
270 pounds
diverticulitis
a cyst in the colon and fatty liver
okay
all right um five foot nine 270 pounds
five foot nine i'd like to see him weigh
170 okay so he needs to lose maybe a
hundred pounds
um these get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
and glutens a wheat broth rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks and i want
them to have
a start out
with three
healthy brain heart packs three healthy
branded heart packs a full dose
everything three times a day
um
if they want to he could just have it
twice a day and take
one dose
of the uh have one of the um
uh
keto bars okay yeah just just do two
doses and take one keto bar a day so he
needs to take the
um
two two uh three boxes three boxes a
month
of the keto bars because there's only
ten in a box
and so it needs to
be able to take one a day
uh
okay so that will help speed up the
weight loss
um then um let's see here
let's see here
all right i also wanted to take
um
three
three healthy brain heart packs per
month
he doesn't have diabetes right i didn't
hear that and so
should i say again
it doesn't mention anything about
diabetes or blood pressure issues
okay but it has diverticulitis this
diverticulitis
uh is due to uh gluten category
we said that in the beginning for this
guy no gluten no we brought right now
just got to stay away from gluten
and it'll be easier to lose weight and
easier to absorb the nutrition
and then he needs three healthy brain
and heart packs from a month three
healthy brain heart factor month a full
dose everything three times a day uh get
two two bottles a month of the of the
msm so you can take three with each meal
and that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the rubber bay bone makes the bone
itself
and um
these things
work very well
as for fatty liver diverticulitis
um
and you know
these cysts that go on
um
in the liver
and so on these things all go away
they're they're non-cancerous
okay they they have to do with
nutritional deficiencies
but this uh diverticulitis
okay has to do with gluten got to get
rid of gluten and that will help the
weight loss because when you have
problems with your intestines you cannot
absorb nutrition even if you're
supplementing all the nutrition is going
out into the septic tank
and so they say well i've been taking
all this stuff and nothing's happening
well that's because you're still eating
gluten
okay
absolutely thank you so much for that
and so for if anybody's interested
um i have lost 100 pounds using dr
wallick's formulas and if you are
interested in finding out more about
that you can go to askdoclive.com
click the contact us
and we can get that information to you
so i've got a whole
whole program set up that includes food
choices and it's going by the tin good
foods bad foods list
which is doing amazing stuff for a lot
of people
many of my clients and i'd love to share
that with everybody here as well
well rebecca we can't thank you enough
for for your story you're you're a
beautiful example of doing everything
right and it paid off for you and the
fact that you're willing to share your
story with everybody i can't thank you
enough
well i'm honored to be able to do it dr
wallach
i really am
let's go to mike with his hand up so
mike go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hello mike
uh-oh it doesn't sound
basic question is on the intestinal
tract
i have experienced the last three weeks
a pain in the left side which
started off like oh you pulled a muscle
but as time progressed we found that we
obviously the stomach's doing uh
processing better creating more gas and
it starts out making you feel like upper
pressure in the chest that we have oh
you've got a heart problem maybe
question so as the time rolls on
we find out no that that pain goes away
with
a belch or
panel uh
release of the gas
so the question is we're down to the
point after three weeks or so that uh
we don't have much pain left but we
didn't
when you expand uh your chest suck in
air well that lower part there's still
pain there from sucking in the oxygen
which means it's out there
stop there
okay so you're you're taking the 90
essential nutrients
uh since february of last year we're on
your product okay
okay good now i also want you to take
our ultimate enzymes i want you to take
two or three of those before each meal
like five or ten minutes for each meal
ultimate enzymes a little bit of water
and so the ultimate enzymes are waiting
down in your stomach for food now make
sure that there's no wheat or iron oats
in any of those food there are no such
things as gluten-free oats
but do take the ultimate enzymes
and
they will digest
carbohydrates down into you know the
basic
building blocks
and they will eliminate an enormous
amount of gas all right
the ultimate enzymes
take two or three of those say like you
say about five or ten minutes before you
eat with you know a little bit of water
um and so that will solve those problems
um
when you have gas that means there's
fermentation going on down there
and what you want to do is make sure
that the
environment your stomach
is
more acid okay you want these these
enzymes the enzymes also have
acid be sure you're salting your food to
taste salt your food to taste because
salt is the basic raw material for your
stomach
chief cells to make
uh stomach acid and when you have
stomach acid
the bad guys the bad bacteria cannot
generate gas gas is generated by
bacteria fermenting
stuff in your intestines in your stomach
and so you want to be sure you're
salting your food to taste we have a
wonderful pink himalayan salt
we have the pink himalayan salt we have
the pink himalayan salt with black
ground pepper in it as well
i use the himalayan salt with breakfast
i use a himalayan salt with a black
pepper for dinner a little a little bit
different taste at dinner time
and um you need salt
and that will help your stomach do its
job your stomach ph needs to be down
around two
and when when it starts moving up
towards neutral towards seven that's
when you start getting all this gas
stuff you need to salt your food to
taste get our pink himalayan salt
from our savory division that's our
that's our spice division that'll be a
great investment for you go ahead and
use our savers
pink himalayan salt and stay away from
the bad stuff
and you will be blessed
we're following you we have nine of your
books already we follow what you say
okay well god bless you give us a call
every couple weeks and let us know
because a lot of people want to hear
your story because so many people you
know go through the same issues that you
do and so they'll be they'll be just
really happy to hear that you're doing
very well and they will say thank you
thank you so much mike
we want to
follow your example okay yeah
lo lost uh
we're gone
all right thank you so much mike and dr
wallach
guess what our two hours is up
i know you've got more to do helping
other
people on other calls and on behalf of
myself and our team here with ass doc
live
um my name again is rebecca kozak our
co-hosts are jonty mccollier nassema
omar ruth ellen sanchez
and we just love and appreciate you dr
wallock yeah and
we you and your team are very sweet we
love you the fact that you're here uh
every friday for people i cannot thank
you enough god thanks you
and i just can't thank you enough you
you and your team are doing a great job
well i i love my team um their
consistency their
just their passion for people and making
sure that they get the information they
need so they can have optimal life
um
and without my team we would not be able
to do this program so thank you so much
and everybody thank you for taking time
to watch this program again get back
with the person that invited you to
watch this program or share this program
with you because they do they care about
you
for those who have
not been shared this program again you
can go to askdoclive.com
we have a store there that has all of
the products that are mentioned today in
our program and we have a contact us if
you have questions or want to have a
free consultation in regards to your
health concerns specifically
use that contact us option
my name again is rebecca kozak have a
fabulous day everybody and be empowered
bye
weekend bye bye
thank you everyone bye bye